bonjour sur le hockey commence à y avoir
des filion on va se filer une première
fois je n'arrive jamais simple où je
vais dire des trucs ça parce que je
kiffe trop sinon hockey jamais lire sur
ta rapidité c'est mieux déjà
[Musique]
c'est le moment où tu te rends compte
que tu adores l'idée est que ce fut
difficile à faire que prévu on va faire
une petite répétition du placement des
chiffres il ya un tracé quai sur la
passerelle extérieure de la nec
[Musique]
ça va c'est le début des répète ça va
encore
à leur demande et pour retourner on va
répéter
sanaa
[Musique]
ça
tous ces feuilles vont s'allumer
[Musique]
et continue à avancer en danse en ligne
par il fait ça il ya vincent elbaz
[Musique]
allez continuez à démanger
ben moi là-bas thirith te plaît si
jusque là bas
voilà c'est plus chaud ici ça oblige à
se tenir
[Musique]
ok je vais présenter les césar mais
avant faut qu'on revoie les bases où je
vais faire une demande à londres ça ou
je vais dire des trucs sans parce que je
kiffe trop sont simples basiques hockey
les césar sont des trophées qui
récompensent le cinéma français
simple les nommer disent qu'ils s'en
foutent bessines l'ont pas ils sont
dégoûtés basique oui on dit nommé tout
le monde croit qu'on est nominé 5
quand je pense que le dernier j'étais
sur mon canapé ou ou basique une actrice
qui passent des essais n'est pas obligé
de se dé saper simple les producteurs de
signer ne sont pas tous des bords
hashtag est basique 120 balle dans par
minute en voir là roger le sens de
l'appel simple la tête de marc sur canal
ouais en clair et en direct basique
vous n'allez pas les races tient à
vincent elbaz basique basique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vasic